Work Excellence.
That mind,
that is what built that company.
And one is a billion dollar company.
Now it's $1 billion company that's in 1.7 billion homes in Asia.
This isn't some mythological idea.
This is a guy who's built a massive company based around these values and that's
a different thing.
He's,
well,
what does he say about common?
Oh sorry,
yeah,
I go off on this deal.
It's cool.
Uh,
so he looks at it as the things that he says and the way that,
and again,
I shouldn't speak for him.
This is the what I've gathered,
throwing things and creating conflict and controversy as your currency is not
something to be proud of.
That's an interesting way of putting it as your currency.
Yeah.
I get it.
You know,
and that sounds because,
and I'm not quite all the,
although I've drank the Koolaid,
I believe in what they're doing and I see it as real,
not only cause my values line up with it,
but I think they are going to grow dramatically as a result of some of these,
the way they see the world.
But not only that,
but I'm still also immersed here.
And I like Connor,
I think of Connor,
I worked for Tsm because Connor fell out of a march to a red carpet to shake my
hand while the,
my boss was watching.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
Like the great,
some of the most interesting moments I've had are with that guy and some of the
most interesting,
you know,
many dozens of hours of trying to figure out what's happening in research and
growth has happened by studying that guy.
And I see his,
the games that he is willing to play as part of his strategy for success as a
fighter and success trying to be,
you know,
successful for his family and his future.
I see it all connected so I don't dislike him,
but I respect this,
this idea that conflict and controversy are not good for us.
I understand that.
But I also understand psychological warfare and I think the condor is a master
of that and that has a huge factor in victory.
I mean,
this is something Miyamoto Musashi use to his advantage.
Um,
you know,
if you read the book of five rings,
he,
what Connor's doing is fucking with people's heads the point where they,
he has space in their head and then Conor goes into the cage,
like loose as a goose,
relaxed and calm.
So he's letting you know,
I don't give a fuck about you but you give a fuck about me and I'm going to fuck
you up right now.
And you're like,
no,
you're not.
You better not.
You can't,
I can't.
This is too much.
And Josie Aldo is the perfect example,
although was so out of composure a although charged at him with that just
leaping left hook and just got fucking waylaid on the way in.
And Eddie Alvarez,
the greatest game day performer,
one of the Great Game Day performance we've ever seen.
And I talked to Ed l that he's one of my favorites and I admire and am inspired
by Eddie Alvarez,
Michael Chandler to,
you know,
those two are like the same guy,
all lost,
you know.
But Eddie was like,
the plan was to wrestle a lot and stay at distance and barely at all.
And I stayed a distance almost the whole time and barely Russell like he was
just like,
it was real.
I cannot,
and
by not accepting it was real coming in and suddenly you find yourself in there
and it's real and you feel different and your,
you know,
your mind is working differently and your hormones are working differently and
who you are and that moment is different and you're like holy fuck,
it's real.
Had I prepared for it to be real?
I could be in a different state right now but I denied that this was going to be
real and now it's fucking real.
Santa Claus is real.
It's real.
I also think you got clipped early on.
I think that's a factor.
You know,
you get caught on the chin like that and your legs give out real quick and your
just,
your brain doesn't work right anymore.
Your body is more quiet anymore.
I think that's a factor.
The ability that Connor has to land those sharp shots that come out of nowhere
and blitz you and come at you so fast and just drop those shots on you.
I mean,
his left hand is a fucking laser beam and that's so good planning.
That's what that is.
The definition of it.
He's so good at landing that shot and he's also good at landing a bunch of other
shit too,
man mean pick you apart.
He's a,
he's a real dynamo.
I just,
I hate to see things like what happened in New York and Brooklyn and he threw
the Dolly at the bus and smashed the window.
It's like,
so it's so fucking stupid.
All that thuggish shit running in with a bunch of other guys and everyone's
screaming at w was what?
What did Khabib do?
He smacked your friend in the face because your friend friend was talking shit.
So you know,
I mean,
and the,
the,
even the way smacked him was pretty general,
you know what I mean?
And Artem called him a coward and he said,
didn't,
he doesn't find Connor's a real fighters.
Like,
listen man,
I know he's Russian.
Your a Russian,
you guys got to sort this out on your own.
That is how they sorted it out.
And it was a pretty calm sorting out in my opinion.
They didn't stop him,
they didn't beat his ass.
But once we get to that point,
I mean I get it,
they have one to eight,
you're doing something and I'm responding,
which he responds.
That happens everyday in gangs,
in wars in Northern Ireland and Ireland and all types of religions that's been
going on forever.
Nobody ever wins when that happens,
it just goes,
it just perpetuates it.
And when you watch it and then there'll be a lot of people,
you see this scenario and like Habib's fans or friends or supporters and condos
and they're like,
he did this,
he did this.
They're both wrong.
And nobody,
everybody always,
when somebody does something bad to somebody else,
they almost always feel like something was but done bad to them.
Very few people instigate that was perceived.
Something happened.
They perceive a slight and you know,
some people you do one thing to them and then they're like,
okay mother fucker,
now it's to eternity.
Right?
Okay,
look,
well that doesn't make any sense either.
Now,
you know,
you look like a fool.
You know,
you just can't throw a Dolly at a bus.
No.
You know,
filled with other fighters because it's so selfish.
I mean,
all those people that got caught,
you know,
I mean Ray Borg got cuts in his eyes.
I mean,
this is the whole thing is a disaster.
So my theory based on bits of information that,
that we have is that Connor,
on some level it,
I mean,
it reinforces
constantly.
If you,
if your kid does something terrible that we know is bad and he'd give him candy
every time they're going to do snatch yet God give her candy.
Every time she does something,
that reward conn has been rewarded.
He gets richer,
more famous,
more influential,
the belts,
and he's been given candy every time he's done this.
And it works.
And I mean,
there was parallels in the political system in America.
There's parallels all over the world that by acting out in these strange ways,
it's so bizarre and unsettling that we reward it.
You know,
Ben Candy for Babby.
Yeah,
that'd be fun.
But that's what's happening.
Right?
And so now we take it and he's,
and then you add the strategy element that you're talking about it,
right.
So he's looking at it and it's like,
okay,
uh,
Habib would be a great fight.
I'd like to fight in Russia.
He likes challenges.
It's just hard.
But let's do it.
Now,
if I create some viral controversy,
which I did with,
with Paulie Malignaggi,
who's a have you,
do you know Polly?
I've only talked to him on Twitter.
I don't know.
I fucking love Polly.
And I liked him as a dude.
I really do.
Um,
uh,
but uh,
so he created that in the work and it's like,
okay,
whether,
how on what level he's strategizing this,
he's like,
let's go do some pushing and shoving with Habib and his guys.
Some given the finger,
it'll be caught on cameras.
What a,
what one thing we know about Connor,
he's always late,
always late.
He didn't plan to get there when they're on a bus.
He planned to get there when they're in the hall.
He planned to get their windows,
a bunch of people around.
It's security and it's easy to manage.
Little push and a little shove in a couple of cameras and all of a sudden his $5
million pay day,
it's a $12 million pay day in Russia and everybody's going crazy.
It'll work.
It's brilliant,
but he's late.
So he shows up there on the bus.
Now the cameras are out and what's he going to do?
He's got to perform.
He came there to perform it,
came there to do a thing.
We showed up and now it,
now it goes sideways and that's the most likely scenario is that it was a,
let's do it.
It'll be,
it'll feel right for us as,
as defending our friend,
but also we'll have some inherent value in the cameras come out and nobody will
get hurt.
I think you're probably right there.
It's got a good,
he's got a good point,
but obviously it's a terrible thing to do and stupid.
You know,
there's,
there's a way to manage that,
but then there's,
people say,
well,
you know,
now it becomes like the WWE and you know,
there's,
there's people that love real fighting that have a real hard time with these
fake WWE style scenarios where you know that,
whether it's Colby Covington,
yeah,
he did a promo recently.
We had a,
a girl by the pool and the girl sat in his lap and she was like,
obviously had a plan script and it seemed kind of Corny people.
There's people who think that's great and there's people fucking hate it.
I'm the hate it.
Yeah.
I'm the hated too.
I don't,
I mean,
I don't have a real problem with pro wrestling.
I joke around about it all the time and I get the fact that people like it.
I don't like that kind of shit bleeding into MMA.
I think it's dumb.